فجوه دوليه مذهله في الاتصالات اتسعت على
مدى العقد الماضي حاليا لا يمكن سوى لسته
وثلاثين في المئه من سكان البلدان السته
والاربعين الافقر في العالم الاتصال بشبكه
الانترنت
في المقابل يتمتع اكثر من 90% من سكان
الاتحاد الاوروبي بامكانيه الاتصال
بالانترنت وفق الاتحاد الدولي للاتصالات
هنا في مؤتمر الدوحه للدول الاقل نهوا
توقع خبراء في مجال التكنولوجيا ان يجلب
اطلاق الاف الاقمار الصناعيه ضمن مدار
ارضي منخفض تغييرا سريعا ويعزز امال
القاتنين فيما بات يعرف بالصحراء الرقميه
عادت شركه مايكروسوفت بالعمل على تمكين
100 مليون افريقي من الوصول الى الانترنت
بحلول عام 2025 رئيس الشركه براسميث افاد
ان كلفه التكنولوجيا تسمح حاليا بالتحرك
بهذه السرعه للوصول الى شريحه سكانيه بهذا
الحجم
واعلنت مايكروسوفت مرحله اولى تشمل خمسه
ملايين افريقي في كانون الاول ديسمبر
واضافت الاسبوع الماضي تعاهدا بتغطيه 20
مليون شخص اخرين
بينما ستؤمن اتصال اول خمسه ملايين شخص
شركه فيا سات الامريكيه كما سترسل شركه
ايلون ماسك
الاف الاقمار الصناعيه الى مدار على
ارتفاع ما بين 400 وسبعمائه كيلومتر عن
الارض للمساهمه في انتشار بلدان العالم
الافقر من الصحراء الرقميه